[Musique]
bonsoir avec six poulains merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france la
stratégie de vaccination française de
plus en plus décrié on l'entend longueur
de journée par notamment les élus et du
coup on tente au gouvernement est bien
de jouer la transparence
oui alors les élus qui sont très
mécontents que ce soit martine aubry
françois rebsamen dans toutes les
régions pas seulement les plus touchées
qui se demandent en fait où sont les
doses comment ça fonctionne on attend
toujours à cette stratégie vaccinale qui
coûterait pourtant si cher à l'état qui
paye des cabinets de conseil pour la
mettre en place
il faut saluer quand même le talent
sémantique d'olive et veyran ministre de
la santé un qui passe de gestion de
crise à flux tendu en expliquant que bah
il gère une pénurie comme il fait depuis
le mois de mars
il n'y avait pas de masque c'était
inutile il y avait les tests ça a été
aussi très long à mettre en place
il n'y a pas assez de vaccins et bien
c'est du flux tendu et tout ça est
génial ça s'organise façon start up
nation
dès que ça arrive on vous dit quand vous
pouvez vous faire vacciner parce que
prendre rendez vous aussi c'est un
parcours du combattant
certains qui voudraient se faire
vacciner biens sont obligés d'attendre
jusqu'au mois de mars
et puis cette question de la
transparence c'est un mot c'est un mot
clé mais qui ne veut rien dire puisque
finalement maintenant dans la
communication du gouvernement
il n'y a plus d'objectifs chiffrés et
datés
on ne dit pas on va vacciner deux
millions de français d'ici fin janvier
on dit on nous allons aller le plus vite
possible nous allons vacciner le plus de
france est possible avec les doses qui
arrivent au compte-gouttes pas au congo
de pardon en flux tendu et tout ça c'est
de bassim super stratégie faudrait les
applaudir pour cette impéritie de plus
pour cette impréparation
de plus alors c'est catastrophique à
l'échelle du pays mais c'est le cas
aussi dans les autres pays c'est vrai
qu'on manque de doses partout en europe
effectivement alexis parce que on voit
que tous les pays européens connaissent
plus ou moins la même difficulté
la faute à l'europe alors la faute à
l'europe et aux partenaires européens
france et allemagne notamment puisque il
a été décidé que tous les pays membres
de l'union européenne ferait une
commande groupée pour faire baisser les
prix pour avoir aussi organisés
l'égalité entre les pays européens et
que tout le monde finalement et
bénéficie de la même pénurie de vaccins
et à l'époque
qu'est ce qui était fait et bien les
français comme les allemands ont voulu
dans le choix des candidats vaccins
privilégier les candidats nationaux
c'est-à-dire pour la france sanofi qui
avait un candidat vaccin qui a pris
beaucoup de retard pour l'allemagne
curve ac et d'autre mais surtout curva
qu'il a aussi été un des vaccins les
plus commandés avec celui de sanofi par
l'union européenne malheureusement les
vaccins qui finalement arrive le plus
tôt à maturité sont ceux de pfizer
biotech et ce2 moderna et là il faut se
dépêcher madame von der leyen de la
commission européenne pousse l'autorité
du médicament européens à mettre sur le
marché ces vaccins à la fin de l'année
dernière seulement voilà on en a pas
commandé assez alors une commande de
nouveau des doses mais le problème c'est
que pfizer lorsqu'il a eu reçu les
commandes c'est le premier qui commande
qui est servi on est maintenant en queue
de peloton
et puis les capacités de production sur
ces contrats européens sur les vaccins
les députés repères ont pu consulter un
seul contrat celui de curva qu'il est
biffé c'est à dire qu'on ne sait pas
quels sont les lieux de production
quelles sont les dates de livraison des
doses et surtout quelles sont les
capacités juridiques en fait en cas de
troubles avec les vaccins
hélas quand est ce qu'on apprend pfizer
ferme son usine en belgique à puurs
parce qu'elle doit augmenter les
capacités de production father sur le
sol européen ne peut produire qu environ
200 millions de doses toutes confondues
que ce soit du duc au vide ou autre
chose et là elle n'a pas préparé la big
pharma le labo father n'a pas préparé de
le fait de pouvoir livrer davantage et
donc on doit attendre les livraisons au
compte gouttes et ça c'est partout
pareil
et rien n'a été fait pour contrer ça on
est totalement dépendant que ce soit
pour les vaccins mais aussi que ce soit
pour la production des masques la
production des médicaments la production
de matériel
dicale la france est tout simplement
incapable de gérer une pénurie sanitaire
parce qu'elle n'a plus les moyens de
production en local les délais de l'ocde
localisation sont passés par là et le
mal est fait alors au delà alexis de la
campagne de vaccination en attend des
annonces mais pour quel résultat
c'est ce qu'on peut se demander parce
que on demande beaucoup d'efforts aux
français depuis le mois de mars
confinement re confinement couvre feu
c'est du stop and go des secteurs
entiers qui sont maintenant sinistré des
entreprises qui commencent à mettre la
clé sous la porte en nombre et malgré le
couac il en coûte 1 malgré la politique
volontariste de dettes à outrance du
gouvernement certainement bénéficient
pas et on peut se demander à quoi ça
sert prenons même les masques
aujourd'hui on apprend que les masques
en tissu sont inefficaces pour les
variants sud africain ou britanniques ou
quoi que ce soit il va falloir passer à
des masques ffp2 alors que faire de tout
ce personnel de l'éducation nationale
équipés en masques en tissu déjà
difficile de respirer sous ces masques
là mais maintenant on leur dit
finalement il va peut-être falloir
changer de masque alors non jean-michel
bancaire ne dis pas ça il confirme que
les masques sont efficaces mais les
mesures qui ont été choisis depuis le
début ont un impact extrêmement limitée
quant à la propagation de ce virus
que ce soit le confinement que ce soit
les couvre-feux les chiffres ne sont pas
extrêmement probant et il ya autant
d'études qui vont vous dire que ça
marche que d'études qui vont vous dire
que ça ne marche que très peu à la marge
parce que ce ne sont pas des mesures
sanitaires
il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de mesures
sanitaires que ce soit les traitements
préventifs et ça commence à venir il ya
une tribune de médecins sur la vitamine
d notamment pour booster les défenses
immunitaires
mais aussi les traitements préventifs
qui ont été moqués parce qu'on essayait
de faire avec ce qu'on avait il y en a
plusieurs
et là on attend le vaccin comme la
solution miracle or que se passe-t-il si
on n'a pas assez de doses que se
passe-t-il si on ne vaccine que d'une
seule dose
et que se passe-t-il si le vaccin ne
marche pas pour les plus de 75 ans
particulièrement et si on a d'autres cas
comme ces cinq morts a nancy où les
enquêtes sont ouvertes mais où il ya
trop de réactions allergiques il ya trop
de choc ya trop de danger le problème du
risque et de
l' avantage aujourd'hui des mesures n'a
pas été pris en compte et on a une
catastrophe psychologique une
catastrophe économique une catastrophe
sociale et notamment pour les plus
jeunes
et là le gouvernement sont totalement
désemparés et ne prévoit pas de plan à
part prier pour une hypothétique relance
économique rapidement dernière
interrogation alexis la france doit-elle
fermer ses frontières aux ressortissants
européens ou au moins leur imposer un
test pcr négatif en arrivant sur notre
sol mais ce serait la moindre des choses
je crois que si on veut éviter la
circulation du virus
on évite tout simplement la circulation
des humains porteurs du virus
et qu'est ce que fait la france par pur
aveuglement idéologique seller en même
temps un et bien on empêche les français
de sortir de chez eux à 18 heures mais
on accueille à bras ouverts tous les
porteurs de virus du monde entier dans
les aéroports avec soi disant des
protocoles mais qui sont très peu
puisqu'il s'agit d'une déclaration sur
l'honneur de dire qu'on va s'auto
confiné et qu'on va faire une
quarantaine mais ça ne compte pas et à
côté de ça vous avez des voisins
européens qui eux ont fermé les
frontières qui décide d'être beaucoup
plus moins laxiste et nous français et
bien on laisse entrer tout le monde
quasiment sous prétexte d'avoir un des
protocoles mais ce n'est pas le cas et
résultats et bien chaque pays européen
est en décalage et une fois c'est
l'allemagne il faut c'est la france une
fois c'est l'italie une fois c'est
l'espagne et le virus continue de
circuler sur le continent comme si rien
n'y faisait
donc à un moment il va peut-être falloir
se concerter au niveau européen pour que
tout le monde ferme les frontières en
même temps elle a même politique
sanitaire en même temps et de dire si on
est sérieux
un tant soit peu et si on veut confiner
les français comme s'il semblerait que
ce soit le cas au mois de février alors
à ce moment-là on ferme tout les
frontières notamment mais qu'on arrête
d'empêcher les français de sortir de
chez eux à 18 heures et c'est sa soeur
en même temps ça ne marche pas en règle
sanitaire
et puis le risque c'est aussi que cette
gestion complètement foutraque de la
crise est bien va coûter l'élection
présidentielle pourrait mener le
maquereau et on sent bien cette erreur
du politique aujourd'hui qui se dit mon
dieu si je fait les mauvais choix alors
c'en est fini pour moi sur la scène
politique non aujourd'hui il s'agit de
répondre de manière sanitaire concertée
et réaliste c'est tout merci alexis
poule à